the righteous power of the infinity
gauntlets versus a human with some fancy
gadgets this battle would be over before
it even started as Marvel Studios gears
up for the final entries in Phase 4 of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe fans are
looking ahead to phase five which kicks
off with Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum
Mania the film's first official trailer
finally gives us a glimpse of the new
threat on the playing field Kang the
Conqueror first played by Jonathan
Majors on the Disney plus series Loki
Kang will be the new Big Bad of the MCU
and the ultimate villain of the next
Avengers movies Chang's gimmick in the
MCU is that he's not just one person but
infinite people from infinite universes
or warring against each other to take
control of all existence if you think
I'm
evil this way
until you meet bye variance well it's
exciting to see this classic Avengers
villain finally brought to the big
screen Kang's role in the MCU going
forward has many fans asking is he
really more of a threat to the MCU than
Thanos after all when Thanos came to
town he wiped out half of all life in
the universe including multiple Avengers
so who would win in a battle between
Kang the Conqueror and the Mad Titan
when it comes to an armed combat with no
tricks allowed it's easy to imagine that
Thanos would beat Kang after all the Mad
Titan is a widely feared conqueror of
planets even before he has granted the
powers of the Infinity Stones in
Infinity War we see him dispose of Gods
like Loki without breaking a sweat and
even taking Stormbreaker to the chest
only slows him down Kang by contrast is
a mere human if the two of them were to
do battle with nothing but their fists
kangwood and doubtedly be in for a
bruising however if Kang were to wield
his formidable 31st Century technology
and Thanos dunsy Infinity Gauntlet it
would be a more even match Kang's
technology she as depicted in Marvel
Comics is leagues ahead of anything
available in the present day an
accomplished scientist Nathaniel
Richards invents a time machine which he
uses to travel to ancient Egypt and rule
over the land as Pharaoh Rama turt
consistently throughout the comics
Kangas proven himself to be a master
strategist who's willing to play the
long game to achieve domination over all
existence Kangas first introduced in the
MCU as he who remains a variant who
created the time variance authority to
stop his multiversal cells from
dominating the Multiverse using a
tempered Kangas gained near omniscience
meaning he knows nearly everything that
will happen throughout time when the
mcu's Avengers take Thanos on at the
height of his power they nearly succeed
in stopping him multiple times first on
Titan and later on Earth during the
Battle of wakanda although Thanos does
eventually win he can't keep the
Avengers from using time travel to goad
him into one more confrontation which he
ultimately loses against Kang with all
his strategies and time traveling powers
Thanos would likely be defeated before
he even knows what's happening it's
worth remembering that Kanga wouldn't
need to face Thanos that is most
powerful either since he could pick any
point in time to attack from in fact he
might not even need to face Thanos at
all why not simply destroy Titan before
Thanos is even born or kill his father
and that wouldn't be the end of thanos's
worries there are infinite versions of
Kang scattered across the Multiverse
many of whom are hell-bent and
conquering every Universe in existence
Thanos on the other hand doesn't concern
himself with other universes or variants
of himself with his sole goal being to
kill half of all life in his own
Universe of origin if multiple Kang's
Ally against Thanos that easily
outnumber their enemy Not only would
they be able to coordinate their attacks
across time space and universes but
they'll also be sharing technology from
all those places even if Thanos defeats
a hundred versions of Kang 100 more
would take their place and he would lose
the odds eventually ultimately while a
hypothetical conflict would be tough for
both parties can advantages against
Thanos would be more than enough to tip
the scales in his favor
[Music]